[Music]
no you don't not yet not yet what I
think she want to take it home may
I hey it's Lindsay and welcome back to
my closet I am so excited because we
have YY coming in and they're going to
style me for an entire week I saw their
showcase back in 2020 and I was
mesmerized by their stage presence
personalities also they're really funny
feel like we could be besties maybe that
will happen today maybe so mity are you
ready to get Fitzy with itsy and Lindsay
bring them in baby no I'm not doing
that
[Applause]
W
hi wow come in come in you guys fit
right in you guys look so cute oh my God
look at these
shoes W very
tall hi we are YY hi I'm NY hey guys I'm
Leah hi I'm n hi I'm CH hi I'm yaa nice
to see you welcome to my
closet amazing so you guys are going to
be styling me for an entire week and you
get to choose what I do each day are you
excited I think the best could be Yuna
because she's really into Fashions these
days I'm really
excited can you each describe your
personal style in three words Gish comfy
and fit mine would be sometimes sporty
some times
cute sometimes I want to wear like
skirts and like girlish kind of clothes
my style is cool casual hip Shake comfy
Gish comfy comfy
com vintage comfy and
over so you're going to be styling me
for the whole five days do you have any
questions for me before we get started
oh you not had something she wanted to
ask before
what you wanted to ask what's your
height I think I'm 5' 10 oh really and
what's your style I'm open to
experimenting different styles so I
would just say have fun with it
because that's a really good question I
do I do yes always have to have like a
jacket or cardig but with her fashion
I'll be cold who wants to be Monday
Friday Friday night no you guys have to
fight over Friday C
[Music]
[Applause]
paper hi I'm Monday I'm thinking of like
a in the morning going out to work
grabbing a cup of coffee that kind of
moves go go tick tock tick Tok tick Tok
tick tock tick tock
no
no oh this is so cute sty your style
this this is like Saturday
moves there's so many
cute this is also cute this is so
cute so
cute Leah you're not here to shoing okay
focus I was actually going to choose
this but this is too long
no wow Friday Friday Friday
Friday what tick to tick ti ti
ti 2 one let's go Level Up Level Up
Level Up Level Up level up this is my
Monday look I chose this white kind of
lace sleeveless top with this skirt
they're all light colored and it's very
Chic and lovely at the same time heels
but very comfy and comfortable heels I
focused on like grabbing coffee in the
morning that was a point with uh
sunglasses like here on the
phone like in the movies for makeup
natural with a little bit of brown
Shades have a good
Monday coffee coffee coffee coffee
coffee coffee I just love how all these
Idols are coffee addicts just like me
Leah put together a main character
outfit and I can't wait to achieve this
Vision Leah how cute is this it's so
preppy it's so feminine am I maybe the
main character in my own romc it looks
like I'm about to have a meat cute oops
I dropped my bag who's here to pick it
up
anybody I'm just a girl I stopped at a
new Cafe and grabbed some coffee and
sweets and met up with joyy is it good
oh it's a little dry I'm not going we're
Keith Le now we give it 7 out of 10 but
the Friendship 10 out of 10 10 out of 10
this outfit made me an entirely new
woman maybe I never got my meat cute but
who needs boys when I got coffee in a
cute fit you
know if you could swap closets with any
other member who would you choose do you
guys share a closet no
no
if I can I will switch with Leah because
she have a mount of claws me too Leah
what's one accessory or clothing item
you can't live without
underwear that's very important genius
you can't beat that
answer hi I'm Tuesday I have a dream
from when I was a little office
woman she have a blonde hair and and
very shortcut so I would choose o blond
hair and office woman like
[Applause]
[Music]
that I saw
this going off this woman how about this
maybe her job is an idol yeah cuz her
Heights is really
tall
no this is so funny oh I really love
this skirt that's your sty really cute
can
I can
I T
yay Friday Friday night at home with cup
of wine glass of wine
oh oh the
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is Tuesday office look I like it I
think just straight hair and then glossy
li no with this glossy you know what I
mean
winking no bags but with black
iPhone black iPhone that's the whole
point just just like
a and card keep have a good
Tuesday a good
Tuesday listen I never know what to wear
when I go into work it's really hard to
find the balance between my style but
also professional and I think youa did
that today so I'm really excited
business W I love this it's so simple
but like so sled you know this silky
blouse with a little peee peep and and
the black boots are like ooh I'm a boss
woman oh this is so girl boss like it
looks like I'm too busy to grab a purse
like I just grabbed my keys and wet you
know let's go to work
baby so obviously I can't get any work
done without an overpriced latte first
and this outfit looked so cute in the
office you better work I had lots of
meetings but I feel like I kind of
worked more than I worked you
know your Instagram pictures are really
cute do you have any tips on how to take
the best Instagram fit
photos you have to look natural that's
the hard part though because you have to
pretend
natural actually I really like to take a
photo with the back side of the phone
not the selfie then the quality of the
picture goes up five of the picture get
a little bit different too so nice it's
like how we used to take pictures before
iPhone hi um on Tuesday Wednesday and
I'm thinking of hi Barbie look because
she and me like a comfy look I want to
make a Barbie look but a little comfier
well let's go on I'm a Barbie girl first
of all this one like a Barbie workout
look yes it is or Barbie wakeup
look did you see Barbie
no but I didn't have time for it I did
oh this is cute too oh it fits to
me may I no
okaying is
here yeah you
like but I think this B someone will
want to you don't have have to think
about the other oh
[Music]
oh that New York C is so
cute the Wednesday look I prepared a
comfy Bary look and for the makeup put
on a pink lips that's
all you're going to take a selfie the
mirror self mirror
mirror still feel
[Music]
like have a nice
Wednesday hi Barbie when I tell you my
jaw was on the floor while I watched her
put this outfit together because it just
kept getting better Barbie time never
too much pink girl how fun is this it's
perfectly sporty and cozy but also
really girly the pink from head to toe
girl girl I think I'm sporty Barbie or
I'm street style Barbie but I want this
Barbie as a Barbie this Barbie made
herself some food and coffee took some
selfies of course opened my itsy album
for the first time and then took a nap
after a long hard day of being comfy
Barbie what is a concept you want to try
that you have not done yet fantasy or
anime
oh I think we
did yeah we have to come up with a new
one
one hi um Thursday today I'm going to
show you my style I think a 4y and comfy
look let's
go yeah I have I have it too you you
have it too maybe all have yeah oh
that's also style yeah it is yeah cute I
think she want to take it home may
I oh oh
so cute because she like the rose yeah I
love L this pant yeah that's very I like
the pant yes and
no no so hot so hot hot girl this days
really like to show off the
back oh
no yes M that's very yey St yes shoes
dog dog shoes so cute so
cute not yet not
yet earrings oh
no my outfit concept is black and white
comfy spoty look no makeup
just and straight hair point
is
exercise or dancing oh Dancing Yeah
dancing it's the choreography have a
nice day dancing thank
you well if you're new here I am not a
dancer so let's just hope that Yi's
dance skills infiltrate my body and I
won't look like a worm you guys I look
like a trainee this is really cool I
love the basketball shorts and these
sneakers but we also have this little
bandana top that's really feminine and
cute and then of course we have the
baseball capat because is it a dance
practice unless you cover half your face
here I go doing it for yi k k i look
like a
worm you know the drill we went to my
favorite dance studio steezy and met up
with Brian from the Allen and Brian what
are we doing today today we are learning
to these cake what's the thing I need to
be scared of today hardest part is
probably this little combo um of hand
moves when you watch the girls perform
cake it looks so cute so easy we're
serving but it was so
hard you guys are seeing me train for
like 10 seconds but I was at the studio
for nearly 3 hours you're doing
great and you know what I think I still
looked like a worm but I had
fun and that's all that
[Music]
matters really
cake
[Music]
what's your favorite clothing Trend
right now watch or jacket yeah she
really likes jackets and coats and kind
of stuff for me hoodie yes yeah I really
like hats I like collecting them what
kinds like any kind of hat just anything
to put on your hat okay cool cool cool
hi I'm Friday my concept is having a
diner with Friends girls night
out let's
go
[Music]
but having a dinner with um bestie so
not too much just pretty pretty is the
main point yes but Friday yeah it is
Friday H
you get it
wowa or this feather skirt she's having
a dinner date but dinner and
[Laughter]
[Music]
next it's
Friday
I'm
done I prepare all black
shikar and um I want you put on red lips
sexy hot and hair is natural um low pone
oh like this have a nice dinner with
friends have a good Friday
bye wow
wow it's Friday which means G know girls
night out the only thing I'm nervous
about is the red lip will it end up all
over my face and body by the end of the
night absolutely but is it a girl night
out if it doesn't end in
chaos why is every look so good I feel
like I'm about to hit a fashion week
look at this red lip why have I never
done this before this must be how
celebrities feel when a professional
stylist Styles them she knew my
potential I did not know it now I'm on a
whole another level sweating it so good
like Miley Cyrus said let's go
G oh I think Chong wanted us to have a
chill classy girls night but the girls
had other plans we had good food tripped
and fell into a karaoke bar we just had
the best time celebrating our friendship
and Womanhood which I feel like was what
Y is all about and it was the best way
to end the week what's your advice to
fans who might be struggling with their
self-confidence actually I want to
really tell them that peop are all
different and the all difference is the
beauty of its own I want to tell them
don't chase the beauty just be yourself
I love it that was very poetic well said
be yourself be yourself in yourself not
only are YY incredible stylists they
were so much fun and so sweet I love
them mity for life thank you guys so
much for coming to my closet and styling
me we had so much fun thank you for
having us so much fun
[Music]
byee